regardons ce paysage dans le désert
saoudien sur cette vue satellite prise
en 2019 il apparaît complètement vide
juste à côté une route semble sortir de
nulle part et des dizaines de camions
l'empreintes car à partir d'ici l'image
a été prise plus tard en 2023 ce
chantier a posé les premières pierres
d'un projet titanesque car d'ici 2029 ça
doit ressembler à
ça salut c'est Lucas en octobre 2022
l'Arabie Saoudite est officiellement
désigné pour accueillir les Jeux
asiatiques d'hivers de 2029 en fait
c'est une sorte de déclinaison des Jeux
Olympiques d'hivers mais pour les pays
d'Asie ce seront les premiers jeux
divers de l'histoire à être organisés
dans la péninsule arabique cette annonce
elle a suscité plusieurs critiques et
interrogations notamment par des
athlètes point de vue écologique ça
paraît être être une catastrophe
extérieurement parlant je connais pas
assez le projet je connais pas assez le
sujet pour pour vraiment dire que c'est
une catastrophe pour l'Arabie Saoudite
ça fait partie d'un projet beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus important vous
allez voir et pour ça le pays met en
avant des engagements pour être zéro
carbone et pour préserver la nature dans
cet épisode de la grande explication
j'ai voulu comprendre comment peut-on
organiser une compétition sportive
d'ivers dans le désert cela peut-il être
respectueux de la nature comme l'annonce
le projet je vous
explique quand on parle de ski au
Moyen-Orient vous avez peut-être en tête
ce type de construction cette piste en
intérieur de 400 m est située à Dubaï
aux Émirats arabes unis voisins en plein
centre commercial pour les jeux
divhivers de 2029 l'Arabie Saoudite
prévoit une station de ski bien plus
importante 36 km de piste principalement
en extérieur pour le moment c'est
difficile de se rendre réellement compte
qu'il peut y avoir des Jeux asiatiques
divers dans cette zone car oui forcément
pour des jeux d'hiver qui regroupent des
dizaines d'épreuves de ski ou de
snowboard il faut d'abord de la
[Musique]
neige ces images ont été tournées à
trogena la future station qui doit
accueillir ces jeux d'hivers et oui il
peut neiger en Arabie Saoudite on peut
lire sur le site du projet que trogena
connaît des températures hivernales
inférieures à zéro et que ce lieu
présente les conditions idéales pour une
station de ski de classe
mondiale en fait ça c'est parce que
trogena n'est pas situé au cœur des
dunes du désert d'Arabi mais le long de
la mer Rouge dans une région montagneuse
entre 1500 m et 2600 m d'altitude mais
pour faire des jeux sur neige il ne faut
pas seulement quelques flocons je me
suis donc demandé si ce type de météo
était courante ou si c'était plutôt une
exception Laur SP doctorante en
hydrologie a d'abord cherché dans
l'historique des observation satellite
des 5 dernières années on n jamais
observé de la neige duré plus de 3 jours
consécutifs sur les 5 dernières années
donc c'était le 11 janvier 2020 il était
tombé à peu près 4 cm de neige fraîche
du 11 au 13 déjà on voit que il y a très
peu de neige en réalité 3 jours plus
tard il y a plus rien pour simplifier
pour faire de la neige il faut en effet
des température en dessous de zéro mais
il faut aussi des précipitations ce
qu'on a vu sur les 30 dernières années
c'est que on a à peu près 1 mm par an de
neige qui tombe mais sous forme
d'équivalent en eau en neige fraîche ça
correspond à peu près à 1 cm de neige en
cumulé sur l'année il faut pas
s'attendre à ce que ces goasia
divers fonctionne avec de la neige
naturelle sur les 30 dernières années en
moyenne selon les données compilées par
Laura Sourp il y aurait donc eu à Trogen
1 cm de neige par an en France une
station comme l'Alpe duise enregistre
une moyenne de 388 cm de neige par an
les promoteurs de Trogen mett en avant
plusieurs solutions pour permettre de
skier à cet endroit et on va revenir
dessus un peu plus tard mais avant ça on
va voir que cette station fait en fait
partie d'un projet bien plus
gigantesque ce projet c'est nom une
immense ville que souhaite construire le
gouvernement
[Musique]
Saien au cœur de ce projet il y a
d'abord the line c'est une sorte de
ville immeuble de seulement 200 m de
large pour 170 km de long voilà ce que
ça donne sur une carte chaque côté
s'élève sur 500 m de hauteur et doit
être recouvert de miroir à l'intérieur
le projet ne prévoit pas de route mais
un train à grande vitesse capable de
relier les de bouts en 20 minutes the
line doit aussi accueillir de nombreuses
activités économiques à terme selon le
site du projet la ville pourra
accueillir 9 millions d'habitants mais
the line n'est pas la seule composante
de néom voici par exemple hoxagone un
gigantesque port industriel celui-ci est
imaginé entièrement automatisé il est
situé le long de la mer Rouge où passe
13 % du commerce mondial de container
donc néom ça vient de l'étymologie
grecque néo et M c'est mustak bal donc
ça veut dire euh le nouveau futur c'est
un étalement urbain de 26500 km² c'est
l'équivalent de la Belgique ok mais quel
rapport avec les jeux divhivers en fait
à côté de The Line et d'oxagone neéom a
un troisième pilier trogena et trogena
est présenté comme une nouvelle
destination mondiale pour le tourisme de
montagne c'est ici dans ces montagnes
désertiques que doivent être construits
les 36 km de piste de ski mais aussi un
lac artificiel géant plus de 2800
logements et chalet 12 Hôtels De Luxe
42000 m car de commerce et de restaurant
ou encore une réserve naturelle
l'ouverture de ce site est prévu pour
2026 et c'est donc 3 ans plus tard que
doivent y avoir lieu les jeux d'hivers
donc en fait c'est aussi la volonté de
promouvoir ce projet de trogena à
travers ce projet complètement fou
d'organiser des Jeux asiatiques divers
dans le nord de l'Arabie Saoudite mais
tout ça est-ce que c'est vraiment
compatible avec la préservation de
l'environnement du climat ou encore de
l'eau
cette vidéo montre des tests faits à
trogén pour skier sur des supports
artificiels mais des épreuves surneige
sont bien annoncé pour la compétition et
le site du projet prévoit 3 mois de ski
sur neige en hiver en fait pour relever
ce défi trogena mise sur un mélange de
neige naturelle et de neige artificielle
plus précisément cet article du média
saoudien à l'Arabia explique qu'environ
75 % des pistes seront recouvertes de
neige artificielle cette neige devrait
être fabriquée de la manière la plus dur
possible avec aucun additif chimique
selon Philippe gullet le directeur du
projet trogena des jeux divivers
reposant sur de la neige artificielle ce
n'est pas vraiment une nouveauté c'était
par exemple le cas aux Jeux olympiques
d'hiver de Pékin en 2022 mais dans le
cas de l'Arabie Saoudite certains
questionne le réalisme de ces annonces
parce que déjà pour fabriquer et
conserver de la neige artificielle il
faut du froid une fois qu'on a produit
donc de la neige artificielle il faut
savoir si elle va tenir l'altitude
moyenne de de la parcelle qu'on a
regardé elle est à 1500 m d'altitude ce
qui correspond à peu près au bas de leur
station ce qu'on a vu c'est qu'en
moyenne on a moins de 1 jour par an où
la température moyenne sur la journée
elle est inférieure à 0°gr pour
comparaison à Toulouse on est à 4 jours
par an j'ai aussi lu que d'ici 2050
l'Arabie Saoudite devrait connaître une
hausse significative de ses températures
à cause du réchauffement climatique de
son côté Clark Williams chargé de la
communication de NEOM explique dans cet
article d'Euronews avoir besoin de moins
3°gr pour créer de la neige ce qui
serait possible selon lui 3 mois de
l'année pour faire de la neige
artificielle il faut ensuite de l'eau et
de l'énergie Philippe guulette prévoit
notamment de récupérer et de recycler
une partie de l'eau de fonte sous les
pistes de ski mais d'où viendra l'eau à
la base toujours selon Philippe guulette
elle sera acheminée depuis des usines de
dessalement sans rejet 36 km de PIST ça
fait des volumes d'eau assez important
l'Arabie Saoudite va se reposer sur le
dessalement de l'eau elle connaît bien
ce procédé dessaler l'eau de mer ça peut
être plus ou moins polluant en fait ça
dépend de la gestion des rejets et de
l'énergie utilisée j'en parle plus en
détail dans cette précédente vidéo plus
généralement quels peuvent être les
impacts de trogena et de neéom sur
l'environnement neéom et donc trogena
sont présentés comme des projets zéro
carbone et respectueux de la nature côté
production d'énergie NEOM
annonce'appuyer sur un déploiement
massif d'éolienne et de panneaux
solaires et j'ai trouvé plusieurs études
qui estim qu'il est effectivement
possible d'alimenter une ville de cette
taille avec ce type d'énergie
renouvelable d'autres experts sont plus
sceptiques notamment sur la possibilité
de déployer ses énergies aussi
rapidement le solaire va être la
principale énergie de ce projet en plus
de l'hydrogène vert dans lequel l'Arabie
Saoudite s'est engagé comme un Paris et
si vous êtes intéressé par plus de
détails sur ce point en particulier je
vous mets le lien de quelques étude sous
la vidéo YouTube si l'Arabie Saoudite
met en avant 100 % d'énergie bacarbone
pour ce projet emblématique ce n'est pas
encore un objectif à l'échelle du
pays en complément le site de NEOM
annonce que 100 millions d'arbres
doivent être plantés d'ici 2030 une
étude indienne a calculé combien
d'arbres il faudrait à nom pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone pour 1
million d'habitants c'est-à-dire pour
que les émissions de CO2 que la ville
émet pour ce million d'habitants soi
absorbé par des arbres résultat selon
cette étude il faudrait un milliard
d'arbres de son côté cette étude de
l'Université Polytechnique de Catalogne
interroge comment une ville en vert
acier et béton construite de toutes
pièces au milieu d'un désert va être
sans émission cela reste à montrer autre
enjeu d'ici 2030 trogena affiche
l'ambition d'accueillir 700000 touristes
par an or dans les stations de sport
d'hiver mais aussi lors des compétitions
international les vols entraînent
souvent une part importante de l'impact
carbone si on regarde maintenant du côté
des animaux sauvages parmi les craintes
que j'ai vu une concerne spécifiquement
the line sa forme linéaire et
l'utilisation de miroirs réfléchissants
peuvent entraîner des barrières pour la
faune locale selon cette étude par
ailleurs plusieurs ONG et chercheurs
pointent la question des droits humains
la tribu qui est installée depuis euh
des siècles sur sur ces terres se trouve
contesté par le royaume parmi cette
tribu il y a des gens qui sont
mécontents parce que les rétributions
sont différentes en fonction euh de la
terre et des biens que possède chacun
d'entre eux sur ce territoire il y a eu
au moins 150 hommes condamnés à des
peines de prison notamment certains à la
peine de mort alors pourquoi faire ces
Jeux d'hiver
ici c'est le conseil olympique d'Asie
qui a désigné à l'unanimité l'Arabie
Saoudite pour accueillir ses Jeux
d'hivers de 2029 l'Arabie Saoudite s'est
présentée pour 2029 parce que il n'y
avait plus de prétendant pour organiser
cet événement pour l'Arabie Saoudite
NEOM trogena et les jeux divhivers
s'inscrivent pleinement dans ce qui est
appelé la vision 2030 c'est une
stratégie nationale portée par lui
Mohamed Ben Salman le prince héritier du
pays qui vise à diversifier l'économie
du pays historiquement basé sur
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures
là-dedans tropogén les jeux divivers et
plus largement le sport comme on peut
voir avec le football ont un rôle
important la nouvelle génération qui
arrive au pouvoir voit dans le sport un
champ économique à investir à pleinement
investir par rapport justement à sa
société qui est composée à 65 % de moins
de 30 ans à partir de 2020 la
montre son envie de devenir l'un des
centres du sport mondial et donc dans ce
but elle va investir dans le golf mais
aussi dans l'ipis le football comme on a
pu le voir mais aussi dans cricket il y
a vraiment la volonté de construire une
vitrine sportive mondiale afin de se
rendre attractive aux yeux du
monde
هم وهاجها الا
هوواال
احناء pour rendre possible le royaume a
déjà annoncé un investissement public de
500 milliards de dollars américains et
le pays lance aussi un app aux
investisseurs étrangers les inv qui V
par rapport à
trog'inriv dans la durée donc en fait
sincr vraiment dans projet dans cette
volonté de créer un lieu pour les sports
divhivers en Arabie Saoudite et afin de
créer l'attractivité de ce projet de
néom mais derrière cela c'est toujours
la question de est-ce que c'est durable
est-ce que c'est faisable pour le moment
on ne le sait pas parce que en fait ça
se repose essentiellement sur des
technologies qui ne sont pas encore en
mesure d'être mises en
service for
usent
com9ished
j'espère que cet épisode de la grande
explication vous aura intéressé comme
d'habitude voici un bonus raconté par
Raphaël le mag j'ai rencontré notamment
à Abu Dhabi des gens du ministère du
sport d'Abu Dhabi qui me raconai que un
moment ils avaient la volonté de
d'accueillir une étape de la Coupe du
Monde de h par exemple à Abu Dhabi donc
en fait c ces visions assez folles ne
sont pas nouvelles mais l'Arabie
Saoudite elle crée un événement bien
plus fou et au sein d'un complexe au
sein d'une ville qui représente l'Arabie
Saoudite de demain en fait vous pouvez
bien sûr poser vos questions en
commentaire et n'hésitez pas à liker la
vidéo si elle vous a plu pour qu'elle
puisse toucher un public plus large vous
pouvez bien sûr vous abonner à brut et
retrouver ici d'autres vidéos de la
grande explication sur les animaux ou
l'environnement et on se retrouve
dimanche prochain pour une nouvelle
vidéo